partner Adam Fox for this one Zack Jones is a
healthy scratch Jimmy py is a healthy scratch
Tyler pitlick back in the lineup we're underway
the Rangers starting with mik saan Jad centering
Chris krider and Capo kako Keandre Miller with a
Pucket a quick shot knocked down in front chase
down by crder Savanah Chad pass back taken away
brought out by Clayton Keller who scored 37 goals
last season brought in Deep by Barrett Hayton a
tough shot Arizona went out and signed some pre
agents six of them actually so they've got some
veterans to go with these younger players one of
them Travis Boyd is on number 72 shot went wide
deflected in go a save by shurkin and it trickles
wide Senter around the boards by trouba kept
in by durit shot by Matt Dumbo was blocked dumo
probably with the best save of the game thus far
I believe it's O'Brian in front as pressure comes
through and then that right there just 24 years
old on right defense Fox across to lingren looks
toward the net and shoots knocked down in front
scramble on and schal ran into Fox good play Fox
with a hit and the takeaway got pako tried to
Center for for zanah Jad is just on shot by fox
went wide lingren over skated extended shift
for that line of the Coyotes out in front for
kako and it just went off his stick the goenda
Ingram gotten a piece of that fox is able to
keep the play going and then it leads to this this
opportunity and phip hedel takes the pass little
pass to Guston drops it off for tro SA inade by
Ingram Uso valaki former Calgary flame picked up
on waivers last year back pass through PR a save
off the left arm Keller gets to it Keller another
one of those players who's 25 years old than the
seventh year chance for a two-on one zed crer
crer [Applause] they go together handed glove
Rangers Tak advantage of it Miller makes the
play there's the pinch here comes the van
on the puck odman Rush patience patience
patience and then the beautiful pass and
no chance for the goal tender that's just
gorgeous passing and the patience by zaban
to pull everyone towards him chases a hit
by fellow number 50 Shawn dery a stuffing Tried
by wheeler was stopped oh great move by wheeler
and a good save by Ingram 30 seconds to go on
the period and shurkin stops play with Clayton
Keller moving in that's for the Rangers
and then troch takes a hit and then here's
the I have had three broadcast Partners Phil
espito got rid of him in two years JD for 20 and
you for 18 it doesn't get any better it doesn't
any better for us he's the gamer rers mve in
again will coie with a setup for tro the rampar
around was blocked the Rangers nearly made this a
two- nothing game there's a beautiful pass and the
the quick shot by troch goes off the post gorgeous
pass from [__] that fires across was blocked by
crder long shot by Jersey one wide it hit Hayton
set up for Schartz he shoots wide 30 seconds to
go in the power play Tire penalty Killers that's
set up score Clayton Keller who had 37 goals last
season the big scoring threat for Arizona has they
just kept moving it around kie was out there the
entire time and he'll end up getting an assist
on this one there it is just off the glove Fox
check by Nick bustad back to zabad now panan looks
shoots deflected wide off the glass tro he checked
by buad who takes it away clearing attempt stopped
by Fox set up zaban Jad missed I think that one
just barely DED off the post that didn't miss by
much so zaban Jad did that a couple of times as
did panan there's that one CH to panan Savannah
Jad crder in front fox saan head save made by
Ingram and then one more and this one is gets
deflected on the way in by by troch the scores in
a 1-1 game here's Logan kie with speed moves in
save just thurin what a move great save now schals
dery Keller to DY for the shot save there's the
rebound Puck cleared into the corner back pass to
dery now to Kell looks for an opening Fe save sh
thurin big save here's Keller that's deflected to
smalz to Keller saved with the right hand and a
clear back come the coyotes 22 seconds left in the
period schaltz with it on the five on
three Dy to killer the shot saved by
sherkin continue to sit so the early five on
three to start period number great 41 seconds
remaining in the power play faceof Win by
Zan had important fox has it back Zan Jad
Fox steps up zad Sav by Ingram and Aon out
to Fox a again save by Ingram what a save
that was oh did he reach out with the right
leg the bad panan gets the pass and shoots
SL vent tro on a
deflection I thought it was tro but paner
leading the skate to the bench you might
hit Stitcher now Stitcher number 51 in front
that was an unbelievable save on the shot by
of bag and then eventually paner right up
the Blue Line will get it again and this
time steter throws out his left leg to try and
make the save watch it 51 on the left throws
out his leg right there and bito take it away
oh great pass by Logan [__] to zooker zooker
taking down well this be a penalty shot yes
yes it has to come back and make a defensive
play so gusterson one of the defenseman was
back on one side and goodro had to try to
defend here is zooker moving it on churin
sa shurin he stopped four for four he's not
even interested and then he puts himself
in a position to do [Applause] this just
doesn't give any look at just standing there
and gets himself set waits for the player to
come in I don't think there's enough
time for him to win it back and get a
shot towards the net and that's it the
Rangers win the home opener two to one